je tout le monde sait ce qu'ils en sont
aujourd'hui sur bioshock infinite alors
un jeu un monstrueusement bien noté
c'est un fps aux graphismes vraiment haï
père jules et comme vous pouvez le voir
là je fais tourner j'en ultra gfa a
rendu en 720p mais en 10 millions de
bits wade à savoir une qualité vraiment
assez cool pour vous alors écoutez je
vais vous expliquer un petit peu
vaguement l'histoire du jeu et les
principes du gameplay tout en se tapant
des barges en robe rouge
non j'aurais donc oued du sort alors on
fait de bioshock
on incarne d'hewitt donc c'est un un
détective à l'inspecteur détective qui
va donc partir à columbia donc une ville
flottante à la recherche d'une fille
et pourquoi est ce qui part dans cette
ville flottante et très mystérieuse à la
recherche d elisabeth la fille donc je
vois pas ce qu'ils appellent le nom
apparaît à l'écran je suis le plus utile
et bien tout simplement parce qu'il est
endetté et que le seul moyen au maire d'
qui retire ses dettes c'est de ramener
la figue bas à la personne à qui dois
des soul tout simplement
donc là au final on était dans le
dirigeable on avait réussi à s'enfuir de
la ville mais au pardon excusez moi des
espèces de pirates nous ont défoncé le
dirigeable et nous ont dit on va le
chercher des armes
et on te rends ton dirigeable bon bien
évidemment là on va pas chercher les
armes on veut juste trouver lisabeth qui
était dans notre dirigeable mais qui
s'est enfui pendant que nous on était
par terre en train d'agoniser voilà en
gros c'est ça l'histoire
alors oui je fais haine pour voir où
faut aller puisqu'il se joue je viens
d'atterrir là en tout cas y'a pas à dire
le jeu graphiquement et artistiquement
parlant enfin dans le sens au niveau des
décors des petits détails comme ça ait
l'air pardon etc
c'est juste impressionnant genre à quel
point c'est travailler c'est beau c'est
justement impressionnant alors que c'est
que ça
nos cristaux ya alors oui donc dans le
jeu on peut en fait boire des potions de
cristaux qui nous permet d'en mettre
deux valeurs des pouvoirs donc la
regarder en bas à gauche ça va changer
j'ai plusieurs pouvoirs que je vais vous
montrer quand on va se battre
j'ai des bons j'ai des corbeaux g de
l'électricité et j'ai un truc qui mais
l'ennemi en l'air le pouvoir des chats
mâles alors quand on voit président ce
que j'aime bien c'est aussi les corbeaux
assez cool celui là alors attendez où on
doit aller au l'âge comment ça il nous
disait rien d'accord ok bon donc on est
là comme des culs et on ne sait pas on
doit aller avait tout simplement là
peut-être bah oui alors je crois que
c'est elle ouais ça c'est elisabeth
alors pourquoi elle s'enfuit parce que
elle a découvert qu'en fait on n'était
pas venu juste pour la sauver parce qu'à
la base à l'aide est enfermé dans cette
cité est en fait on a été obligé de lui
avouer qu'au final si on l'a on l'a on
l'a sauvé comme ça et tout c'était pour
la rendre aux mecs pour ne plus avoir de
dettes et du coup elle elle fait laisse
moi je veux pas les voir avec celle que
tu te tais pas
donc oui elle est là vous avez dit what
the fuck qu'est ce qu'elle vient de
faire en fait elle est là le pauvre et
des watts elle peut ouvrir des brèches
comme ça e
donc genre là on voit le revoir un
événement qui se passe je sais pas où et
à elles couvriront la débat voilà par
exemple un train qui passe elle peut
faire n'importe quoi à mener n'importe
quoi dans ce monde là tout simplement
voilà donc la n va sont fouillés et
voilà elle s'est barrée est la l1 on
entend donc en fait je crois qu'il a
juste traversé le mur la brèche monnaie
de l'autre côté du nom alors sauver les
abeilles tard comment on va faire du
coup est ce qu'il ya pas des trucs à
promenade dans non les flèches thuram à
la flèche
c'est indique toujours la bonne chose
mais flèche sauf quand tu as fait une
erreur on contrôle alors que dell la
fumée j'ai des petits ralentissements
des fois je sais pas trop à quoi s'est
lié mon pc qu'il merde alors waouh
non mais regardez moi ces graphismes
c'est hallucinant quoi c'est vraiment
hallucinant on a des cristaux alors
qu'est ce que c'est là bas comment on
fait à sauver les abeilles
j'ai envie de vous montrer sa way up on
peut s'accrocher en fait comme ça au
rail pour aller à un endroit souhaitait
alors ça c'est gouttes
je suis en combat mais j'ai bon moi je
veux juste rentrer à ce qui fut un
combat
bon bah voilà alors je vais pouvoir
montrer l'utilité des powers et paquin
pouvoir qu'on a alors on va utiliser
quoi on va utiliser le cor vosges est
belle quand vous regardez pitbull les
1000 cambo c'est tellement style et
j'adore alors on peut aussi jouer au
style tort évidemment non madame split
corp boum boum voilà du coup de coeur
voilà en revanche est à étapes des
esquives et tout lui a pas trop tard at
on ajouté
voilà on l'a eu il y en a 1 derrière je
suppose non non bon vent monsieur ça les
mecs bien pris de recherche est alors
évidemment il ramène chez pas combien de
dirigeables ou ben arfa technique des
corbeaux alors si vous pouvez bien voir
les campements littéralement les ennemis
passer un petit truc qui fait une place
et qui fait on voit les ennemis se
décomposer un peu en gros [ __ ] la page
font mal alors ce qui a pas moyen de
reprendre par ici à la base notre amie
elizabeth elles nous aident en fait elle
vous des brèches où il ya des tourelles
et cetera
malheureusement quand il n'est pas là on
franchit un peu plus ah ouais $ b e s
des kits de soin et cetera
voilà on va améliorer nos corbeau
meurtriers aux annonces j'ai cru que
j'allais puisqu'il fallait qu'ils
transforment en pièges des petits pour
youtube explosif donc bien évidemment et
un petit aspect rpg dans le jeu on peut
améliorer le pouvoir et
et des fois on trouve des équipements
qui nous donne des compétences spéciales
genre après avoir tué un ennemi à vous
gagnez transition manger n'importe quoi
alors
super dur à voir un mec pour meeke a
déteint mais merde
o comment je galère mais il va ou quoi
lui la bâche et qu'est ce qu'ils voient
là mais c'est la guerre cette partie on
sait quoi faire le tour par tour
on pourrait s'arrêter là à ce moment se
faire cela c'est romain et le 1
alalalala ils ont vraiment beaucoup de
vies alors différents types d'ennemis
évidemment 1 2 3 et ni casse couilles
j'ai pu de christophe genoud pu faire de
power regardez le lieu là bas les
masques ou quoi non ça que je vais faire
du tout
alors là c'est une espèce de toi
automatique à la con c'est bon j'ai eu
un petit coup dlabaja là bas casse toi
il est mort dégage un volailler morts
enfin je crois qu'on a un peu tous
dessus et non ils sont encore là où
j'arrive là église nda domaine on va
prendre la petite mitraillette on va
descendre juste là et boum parfait mais
bon les a tous eu cette fois tu peux
enfin sauver les abeilles à l'ego
oh malheur est pas tous barrés la [ __ ]
une brèche à l'est où est partout
mon truc à fond qui la suivent sur ce
rail waouh ok donc en gros l als lcl en
fait qu'elle va pas être l'oreille là
vous voyez elle est la voix il est pas
content lui
oh
al battar
est ce qu ils les abattent elle va nous
sauver ou pas
brèche fait une brèche
ok ça fait quand même apparaître dans la
brèche depuis c'est voilà celle qui nous
a sauvés on est d'accord
elle est et il faut ce sont des armes
pour toute une armée de révolte et voilà
c'est ce que je vous ai dit la vidéo est
là des [ __ ] de dieu un super bien
modélisés les personnages super
j'insiste un succès pas super super
alors cela pète comme hot chip la tête
tractage eu alors un proche ou un bon
goûter
alors ouais on va quitter les quais de
la zone n'a plus rien à faire ici alors
on n'a plus qu'à trouver maintenant
qu'on a récupéré note élisabeth parce
qu'en fait dans le dirigeable ce que je
vous disais tout à l'heure avant qu'on
se fasse donc défoncé par des pirates
elle nous a mis un gros coup de clé à
molette après qu'on lui ait dit qu'en
gros on veut juste la ramener un ami
enfin un mec chez qui on est en effet
pour ce annuler ses dettes elle nous a
mis la clef à molette elle a réussi à
échapper aux pirates pendant prononcé
péta par les pirates et on l'a retrouvé
au final table elle ne boude encore un
prime ne connaît pas alors
alors là il ya juste un petit truc
aiment ce jeu va activer une option
la synchronisation verticale même si ça
prend un peu trop de performances de mon
pc on risque un peu de la guerre mon
avis non aubin nickel j'aurais dû la
mettre dès le début merde ça fait
tellement laguë d'habitude ce truc
illégalement cherchons une deuxième
entrée au moins d'entrain à killington
flèche fléchés de moi ça s'annonçait
trop la vie ces trucs faux crocheter
tiazi bien que j'étais là on peut lui
demander de crocheter voilà ok elle
apparaît d anormal moi je ne sont pas
les vaches rouges après l'artois se sent
de mieux en ascenseur de service il nous
mènera hockey fera tuer pour le même
prix alors c'est par là bas c'est super
si les ce principe de deux flèches par
terre c'est pas un espace à un petit peu
comme des espèces au fond c'est un peu
le même délai arme et sur personne kiev
comment qui nous aiment pas
oh merde travaux et doit tiens je te
console oh merde au nom si tu as un bon
ok je m'en veux trop beau je pense quand
même ça ok c'est la guerre alors on va
essayer de jouer en mode qu'est ce que
vous faites
alors je me trouvais toujours compter
sur moi elle est mais vous êtes
carbonisés comment ça vous êtes encore
en vie commence à quoi largo winch est
ce juste débat alors ceux qui n'aiment
pas cela en fait des robots en fait on
peut tirer dans leur dos pour la section
plus de munitions
la plus belle dans rien amical merci
c'est ma belle off et on line dance nous
est contée chantée engrenage voilà qui
l'a alors on a failli l'avoir enfin un
petit tour banques courent courent
courent ouah aussi très tendu là du coup
j'ai un vieux puisque les films un
invincible le truc sérieux terme et des
pistolets c'est vraiment nul 1 n'ont pas
beaucoup de dégâts station j'étais pas
là que j'ai amélioré ses bons éléments
bon là il y en a eu on a eu du bol d'or
on a récupéré des cristaux alors qu'en
fait ils sont pleins voilà match pour la
mâchoire
c'est bien ce mec c'est moi mort des
demandes de collecte lâchez-moi à
l'homme sa faute
retournez à l'école bande d'enfoirés
faisant les taux sont au vert et toi tu
ne pars dans la tête
voilà j'ai tendu très tendu
mais attendez on est dans une armurerie
ils devraient avoir bondi de bain bien
venir
john et moi n'est pas les gens j'en sais
que vous avez des remarques faites pas
un combat car en un nouveau pouvoir
ah non c'était juste des cristaux
puisqu'en fait qu'on a on en obtient 9
au pouvoir c'est exactement sur cette
forme là à savoir dans une bouteille
notre brave ami c'est sur un marqueur
tricolore et je combats de quoi prendre
va prendre un kit de soin voilà nickel
alors doit aller où trouver un moyen
d'entrer à filton ça
les rangements à j'ai cru qu'on allait
pouvoir faire tous les branchements on
et les milliardaires
mais non dommage bon alors ça doit être
là dedans effectivement ici boum
j'appelle la chercheure
boka le casier de slate il travaillait
ici mais je sais le journal de ma mère
ou slate l'a t-il trouvé mon mari
prétend que l'enfant ni de la jav est un
gros blanc j'étais à fond dedans
vox aux fausses amies on va lire capital
chance ne grandira pas cette fois oui
j'ai réécouté de vox open 1
tu te tais et les avais tu encaisses
rigole pas moi qui m'a fait enfermer
elizabeth
je veux juste me fier de cette ville je
vous en prie puisqu'en fait il avait
fait enfermer
ok on a eu la fin du boxeur phone
prophète et tout fait dans son berceau
merci au revoir
alors boom transunion de notre génial
c'est vraiment vraiment impressionnant
gagnent franchement j'avais dit non
allo majorité phone 7
j'en ai aucune idée
moi de bugs il a l'air ravi de vous
rencontrer
ok c'est cool on peut passer quand ça
naît ça encore waouh
ah oui effectivement le mec il a un ego
pas trop dingue à la flamme statue en or
deux mois de 300 m voilà ce sera beau
gosse quoi soulager mais je fatigue et
macky sall avait alors déclaré m attaque
faute de fait même pas qu on n ose
regarder attendait
que mon jeu designs live
vaches
ok vaches
voyez ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure dans l'autre qu'artistique c'est
ça dont je parlais ça c'est
impressionnant
bonjour vous trouverez de quoi vous
approvisionnez pour contre alors canon à
main merci alors des fois nous donne de
l'argent les cristaux on va prendre mes
crochets pardonnez-moi mais monsieur
fink ne portent d'intérêt qu'à ce
monsieur pourquoi désolé mademoiselle
toute question concernant la quant au
revoir monsieur est adressée directement
à monsieur flics
désolé les abete
où allons nous donc allez pas comment
place de la ferveur salut j'aurais pu
tuer au ce qu'ont fait les gens ce qu on
le fait
euh je me souviens du club j'aime bien
cette arme aluminium oh la vache à lait
plutôt efficace à ces longs mois moins
qu'on puisse dire
bon on va tous les faire aller là bas au
jeu ça va on les gère quels sont les buy
telles sont les veille on a tous
défoncés ça va se débattre et plusieurs
bons mois les troquets s'était même fait
qu'un simple j'aime bien les mais
c'était mignon on a tous les français
alors que tu risques donc à faire alors
ce qu'on doit aller on doit aller là bas
là bas non non [ __ ] heureusement qu'il
est surpuissant ce revolver là je peux
vous dire je suis à mort depuis
l'éternité
alors ouais mais j'ai pas assez de sous
j'ai que 200 dollars je peux
concrètement rien à voir alors êtes vous
voyez ça que je vous disais je trouve de
l'argent et nous le donne ça c'est cool
j'aime bien
attendez ça vient de cette faille j'ai
jamais entendu cette chanson ne pense
pas que quelqu'un l'ait jamais entendre
c'était assez de sang y avait acheté des
chiens bordel de merde
trop stylé je veux qu'on aille là où il
y avait la brèche bordel sépare ou pas
ou c'est par là hop
allez moi je prends toujours à quettehou
ya qu a eu du bon allez entrer nous
sommes maintenant dans la zone est ok
bon alors on va juste trouver l'armurier
après on mettra on arrêterait la vidéo
sinon j'aurais pas le temps de le
peloton tout simplement alors qui sont
ces beaux jours sous l'arbre de la body
jusqu'à l'élimination
bonjour ok y'a quelqu'un l'ena quelqu'un
a tout saccagé
ouais effectivement forces de police du
coin sûrement tpt la tuque à ces
annonces il pleure on l'entend
[ __ ] liu
ah bonjour j'habite avec sa femme voilà
me désolé de vous déranger je cherche
son monsieur linh les morts
ah ouais show bagatelle il est où ce
club
s'il vous plaît où est le club les
doubles à sion vraiment bien faire
j'aime bien les flics faut aller au club
bagatelle et sauve et jeanine et bien
écouter les gens on va s'arrêter là si
vous voulez d'autres vidéos sur bioshock
n'hésitez pas j'en ferai peut-être si
j'ai le temps où quoi sur bioshock en
tout cas le tomb raider épisode 8
arrivera demain encore excusez moi pour
ne pas l'avoir mis en avant et puis
voilà tu veux te vend depuis ça bientôt
djiké bien bonne chance pour ceux qui
ont leur bac blanc comme moi et voilà à
peace